welcome to this video I playing a
controversial play it seems dirty sexy
money and he got disconnects against him
because people probably think that he is
cheating or something so let's see i see
murasa which just disconnected against
him once so let's see what happens I
have played him once before and i won so
let's see what happens I'm going to play
this super doll line no I'm a spoilsport
and see what happens what what is it
that he can do here against me that's a
very safe line it tough to do anything
is black yeah in most cases here it's
even black who is slightly needs to be
slightly cautious it's not not something
substantial but in in most cases why
this is even having a little bit of
something at least in normal let's say
in tournament chess but you have some
time and in blitz some all kinds of
crazy things might happen yeah the
reason why white sometimes little bit
better is asleep on I have rook see one
possibly coming and very often also his
bishop on g7 it's not just a great piece
it looks at the e5 pawn rook at seven
Bishop fa d6 is a way to play ok it took
them I can just recapture and no okay so
look see one runs into night e 2 that's
not a great idea taking only five is
very lame on d4 I mean sorry taking on
deform it's very lame
not bad though it's not a bad move I
still like to play rock you rock see one
somehow the OSS night f5 now it's still
maybe not at five kingi to preparing
Roxy one so going here just playing it
very very save him
what b6 is a bit strange looks a bit
strange this move getting him a backward
see porn I mean it's nothing that is
terrible for him but I didn't expect
that so Brooks III just doubling I guess
check okay yeah you can argue that you
can always do that yeah I understand
this is certainly always possible and
you hear he just keeps us this the
seaport covered with them we should one
you five let's see to something that I
can do it's still potentially a little
bit more convenient for wide we'll see
one
can also take on default it's not really
helping much and maybe just taking a day
phone okay
check this is so great so anything bad
happening to me I don't see it I'm
wondering if I'm overlooking something
like a meat or something here I'm
overlooking something I was a crook c6
mix III check King b5 rook c5 is there a
meter or something I simply don't see it
you can also just take I mean I already
don't don't get it which is probably I'm
overlooking stuff probably but yes they
don't get what he's doing check I'm one
pawn up and b6 hangs and I mean what is
the big big deal so i can take here i
can take two but okay I have to take
that check and I want them I want the
aisle the de point you to move at one
point and like this try to get it moving
these things for up c7
Wow Kim can do that that's true that's
certainly true
okay we've gotten it anyway and they
spawn it's got one time or 10-minute
extra edges just completely drawn but
here's the the time you know let's do
not to pre move for any any funny stuff
oops draw effort
some it's even though oops even though
the 50 moves are easily doable DRA
offered stalemate yeah for this one yeah
sure I probably should have won this
somehow but I don't really know Chad
looks I mean maybe I should I can just
take the form yet i just lost a movie
I'm check check it looks critical care
really looks critical for black but
maybe it's just blocking it with the the
opposite term opposite colored bishops
all the time this line is super safe
choice where you really run almost zero
risk of losing but it's on the other
hand difficult to try to play for win
maybe this was interesting now this
would therefore dad this would have been
interesting actually this is this is
some advantage for white not great but
it's something got the better King and
so on Joe or Kings afore he never ever
got close to getting anything in this
game but it was difficult to really do
for really go for something something
something great for white as well okay
well at least a draw against this very
high rated player thanks for watching